[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i mentioned before the commercial break
today should be a national holiday we've
heard of d-day
how about e day on this date 1979
espn was launched yeah
a national sports holiday it should be
big day
i was going to say that the knack played
shea stadium but that was is that true
no i don't know oh okay
uh
i wonder what it's like though when you
play a game and then you go home
do you watch espn
eli manning joins us now hi eli what's
up dan how you doing i'm doing i'm doing
great what was it like though you play a
game
and then were you more apt to watch
sportscenter
win or
or lose
i think you watch it no matter what i
think you it when your game comes on if
you won you watch it if you lost you may
flip the channel for a little bit you
know you really you know you want to
keep up with the rest of the league and
the other teams how the other teams in
your division did the team you're
playing next week how they did see some
highlights see some of your buddies that
you played college with or you played on
other teams with uh and see how they did
as well see how my brother did when you
know when when he was playing did you
ever get mad and yelled at the tv
when we would do your highlights
yeah but not at not at you uh more you
know i would see what happened uh during
that play you see you know offense line
miss a miss a block or a pass get tipped
up or you know so you might be yelling
at a player but i never never yelled at
you dan i would never do that i
appreciate that
peyton did but you would you would never
never do that
a hundred percent he would and then he
would call you and leave you invested
here
you did wrong
and analyze your
you know broadcasting skills uh if
you're analyzing his football that is
true that that is true i never played
the game i heard that from quite a few
athletes what was the biggest difference
though between you and peyton as as a
quarterback
you know i don't know i mean i think i
think um
you know i think we both tried to be
students of the game trying to
understand where to go
and just uh i think you know peyton did
a lot more by checking at the line of
scrimmage and you know doing the no
huddle offense he kind of created
that that that style of play and
basically being the offensive
coordinator on the field and so it was a
lot of commun
communication signals everything going
on we were a little bit more of kind of
hey call a play if you have a terrible
play you can check out of it but let's
just let's call the play that's run were
you allowed could you have done what
payton did at the line of scrimmage with
the giants
i think it's it's a lot i mean it sounds
great um you know it's kind of one of
those deals you really have to earn the
right to check a play i mean anyone can
check a play but are you checking into
something that's better than what you
had called and so it's got to be a lot
of communication with the head coach
with the offensive coordinator of being
on the same page and you know some of it
is getting up the line of scrimmage
quickly and hey seeing what they're
doing and you know it's kind of what
colleges do and all of a sudden they you
know fake a snap and they look to the
sideline that's basically kind of what
was happening except the coordinator is
still in your ear can tell you ideas and
plays but it's got to happen before 15
seconds on the play clock run out or
then the communication cuts off
a lot of times we'll see athletes
they're forced to retire i don't know if
you felt you were forced to retire but
if they're gonna draft your success or
at least try to
but that pull that tug of war of wanting
to play but then you got your kids
growing up and then all of a sudden it's
you know where are your priorities did
you have that conversation with your
wife of could you have played another
year could you play someplace else or
was it just time to come home
you know
we had the conversation and i think i
was i was definitely leaning
uh you know towards towards retiring i
think it's just you know i had a great
career 16 years with one organization
you know but you know definitely thought
about it for a little bit and just
discussed hey you know do we want to
move our whole family to a new city you
know what what am i playing for i'm
going in the year 17 you're probably
going to a team that's not you know very
good they're need of a quarterback are
you just playing because you want to
play are you playing for a championship
and is it worth kind of you know
uprooting your family to move on and and
it just it wasn't worth it to me and i
was you know i was happy kind of hanging
it up and just being a fan and and
moving on to my next next venture and so
um you know i think that's what made it
easy for me to continue to be a fan and
to go to games and watch football on on
sunday i wasn't bitter i wasn't mad hey
i could be playing better than this guy
i was just i was ready to hang it up and
and just you know be a dad and uh and be
a fan
if you had to make a bet on the rams
making it back to the super bowl or
missing the playoffs
who
you know i think they're talented i
think they i would make the bet that
they a better chance of getting back to
the super bowl than missing the playoffs
i think just
with the the talent they have uh on that
team uh i don't think they'll miss the
playoffs we're talking elon manning the
uh two-time super bowl champ and emmy
nominee
best newcomer is that what it was
emerging star what what was the category
any of them i was nominated for dan i
can't even remember all right i
understand actually i think i'm a win uh
amy award-winning uh actually you know
we could we can get that well that's the
show so you like i'm talking about
individually it'd be like you know when
when i won i would i i'm an mvp
you know when the team won it's like you
know we won a super bowl so there's a
difference in that okay
so we we even though yeah we wanted an
enemy but i did not want an emmy okay i
got it uh
does peyton eat before you go on the air
as opposed to eating on the show
that's that's just the time difference
you know east coast you know the games
at 8 15 8 30 i eat before but he's in
denver at mountain time you know game
comes on and sticks he got a prep before
so he he gets hungry at half time and
you know it shows that you know he's not
like i gotta eat because i have to eat
he is starving like he has to wolf down
food and he's got basically five minutes
to get it down
and that's my favorite part of the whole
show eli he eats like he's joey chestnut
like he's she's trying to win a
competition here
it's uh we've we've it's been that way
since he was little we've had the i
remember like when he went on his first
date when he was like 16 we had to talk
about like all right what are you gonna
order just so like we gotta think
through this like you can't order
spaghetti that's just gonna get all over
yourself and be on your face like you're
you know the girl is gonna run away but
uh so like let's think through this and
let's like remember take a bite fourth
down like you know take a breath every
once in a while let's let's you know
maybe eat before you go on the date so
you're not starving man your brother got
so upset when your father
said called uh peyton longneck
and and we were
and he was on the show and he goes long
neck
and i went oh my god there is no way
peyton likes that nickname
no well i think since before surgeries
he's not he's you know
oh he hadn't had next neck reduction
surgery
yes that's what it was
breaking news peyton manning had neck
reduction surgery that's a big story
yeah
uh it looks like you have a lot of
products there in front of you first of
all is that is that a tv set there like
like whose room is that that you're in
uh i'm at the verizon store right now
and so this is kind of a prep
some of their products this is a karaoke
machine i think so that's exciting i
don't know if i'm singing for you dan
but let's go what's what's your go-to
song
oh oh you never close your eyes i i
don't know if i should sing that to you
uh that sounds weird
usually
it's always a good one okay uh what what
other toys you got there in front of you
well just you know here you know it's
just with the whole world it's really
about verizon and they're you know 5g
ultra wide band and the fact that now
you know you're watching you're watching
games on on tv at home you're watching
games on your phone it's all about
having a fast reliable connection and
you get that and i rely on verizon and
their 5g ultrawide band so whether it's
your business needs with you know
verizon business or um you know you just
want to stream games it helps me make
sure i'm not going to miss one play of
football just because i know i'm gonna
be connected and be able to watch all
the games give me the phone number
in your phone that might surprise us
not the number
the most famous person in your phone you
want me to read out your number right
now
who's the most famous person in your uh
verizon phone
uh payton probably i don't know i'm not
i don't know many famous people i'm not
the i'm like the boring guy like i meet
people but i never think about asking
for their number like that would be
weird i can't ask for i can't ask for a
picture and i can't ask for a number i
just it's against you're getting wait
when's the last time you asked for a
picture of somebody famous or an
autograph
uh kevin federline 2009.
[Laughter]
there you go
is that true
that is true yeah yeah
i've been know six though i think it's
nine but
why didn't you ask for britney spears
with a with a picture or not
i didn't see her i just saw i saw
kayfabe
you know it's all about taking a picture
and then sending it to your buddies of
who they
if it's like someone cool if it's like
ryan reynolds or someone that's like
yeah he's famous but that's not that's
not like that's not funny so it's got to
be not nothing
okay sorry you don't understand yes like
okay finally
will you ballot will you validate this
story before i let you go
and that is that when people would want
to get a picture with your brother
and you would take the picture
you always cut off peyton's head
that
so you took the picture
and then vayne's head was never in the
picture is that true eli
that is true
we're going back to college so at least
i was in college you didn't have not
everybody had a cell phone let alone no
no phone had a camera on it so it's all
like the digital camera
kind of like
like the throw away you know roll up
camera and so you would just if someone
had to have a camera that asked for a
picture and peyton's you know six
six six you got the long neck and so i'd
take a picture it would be you know all
of them and just peyton's head cut off
when they go and print it like four days
later they're like i promise you that's
peyton in this picture that's him you
can see like he'll try to match his belt
with like another picture but like so i
ruined a lot of pictures i apologize to
all those people now i'm sorry
uh love the show congrats good luck with
uh verizon today i'm sure you're busy
and uh as always thank you eli
thank you dan always a pleasure that's
eli manning he's won awards he's a
nominee and an award winner his team won